a woman believed to be a vocal critic of
islam
has been stabbed in london the incident
happened at hyde park's famous speaker's
corner
her injuries are not said to be
life-threatening but you may find the
following video
disturbing this footage shows
a large group of people gathered in the
park the victim is towards the
back a man dressed in black can be seen
violently
striking the woman
well while the authorities and major
media outlets
did not name the victim or give any
specific details bloggers
and activists identified her as 39 year
old
hatunta she is said to have fled
turkey after announcing islam for
christianity and was regularly seen
preaching in hyde park previously the
woman was escorted by police from the
park over fear of attacks against her
and was even banned from speaker's
corner after a number of threads
one thing that hasn't gone unnoticed
though is that the time
of the attack she was wearing a shirley
hebdo
t-shirt the french satirical magazine
has been in the spotlight
many times over its caricatures one of
them portraying the prophet muhammad
you'll remember led to a series of
deadly islamist attacks back in 2015.
however her shirt didn't depict the
prophet instead it showed a kiss between
a cartoonist and a muslim preacher
caption love is stronger than hate now
much of
the media here has either focused solely
on the fact she was wearing a
charlie hebdo shirt or that it was a
woman who was attacked
in hyde park while london's mirror has
been criticized for not even
acknowledging
the incident if a woman is tapped in
hyde park and mayor of london sadiq khan
doesn't mention it
did it even happen so sadiq khan i
thought speaker's corner was a place
where debate and critique could take
place freely
why haven't you condemned the atrocious
stabbing in the park yesterday
a little quiet on this latest london
stabbing sadiq khan
well police in london are warning
against making any premature conclusions
over the reason behind the slamming
i would ask people not to speculate on
the motive for the attack until we have
established the full facts
we discussed with our guests why much
of the media's coverage of the incident
left many
pertinent details out it should be
a main story and i think it's because
some
of the media are concerned that it will
inflame sort of anti-muslim tensions
but that would be totally wrong because
the vast majority of
muslims are against that sort of
conduct so it would be uh
the responsible thing for the british
media
to actually um mention this story not
keep it quiet i think
very sadly it was a conscious decision
of those media to do exactly that
and i think it's irresponsible and i
think it's wrong
and that there always will be people who
are
convert from one religion to another
there
are many religions in the world and it
happens all
the time and we can't have a situation
where uh one uh you know
somebody who purports to be uh in a
particular religion
uh believes that it's their right to
attack somebody uh because they've
changed another
uh religion we live in these funny times
where we think that if
we mention atrocities like this
that would be somehow viewed as
islamophobic or some sort of a bigotry
or racism
british public or at least the
government is afraid to still talk about
this issue
and as i said less we talk about it
worse this problem is going to get
i'm actually genuinely worried that
these kind of things are going to happen
a lot more unless we have a genuine
honest discussion about this that
blasphemy
has a place in a free society
you